brian and denise let me tell you
hundreds hundreds of people gathered
earlier this afternoon here outside of
the federal courthouse to really voice
their concerns over today's u.s supreme
court's decision now many came out here
to cry
and others just came out here to show
support
[Applause]
people take away your right to me then
what do we have we don't have america
anymore shauna trahan says she is still
overwhelmed but she couldn't hold back
her emotions when she came across this
rally in downtown and her granddaughter
began to ask questions i hope she never
needs this right
but
if she ever needs it
and doesn't have it
that's hard
that part that part is hard i mean she's
a baby but i mean she needs to have a
right
[Applause]
trahan was one of hundreds gathered
across the federal courthouse friday
evening along las vegas boulevard
seeking comfort and hope after what many
call a massive punch to women's rights
it was one of our core issues from the
beginning and you know i saw somebody
today 50 work 50 years of their activism
for nothing and you want to make sure
she doesn't feel that way
but it does feel that way to a lot of
people jerry burton with the women's
rights organization nevada now says the
rally came together last minute after an
outpour of residents both women and men
seeking a way to voice their frustration
once you know they're done getting rid
of abortion rights they're going to come
after gay marriage they're going to come
after other rights as well so it's
important to stop them in their tracks
for this group organizers say it's all
about getting out and voting for a
change a step this grandmother hopes
will make a difference in texas is it
doesn't matter if you are raped
or molested
it's a lot
it's too much
will organizers emphasize that they will
not be giving up they tell me that they
will keep pushing forward no matter how
long it takes christian casa is live
local now